if you were watching the web traffic to
chat GPT since it was released by open
AI you would have seen the visits peak
in April and then start dipping down
some people thought maybe AI generated
text was just a fat after all but now it
seems like maybe that was just summer
break I was not prepared for the amount
of students that were using it it felt
like a cheap code right about 60% said
they use cha gbt 91% have at least tried
Chachi it's a high number after the
headline started that students were
using it to cheat I used it to cheat
pieces of writing that are grammatically
perfect everything was capitalized
correctly and if I was in their shoes if
there was a way that I can do my school
work like quickly I would have been that
kid oh I would have took it I would have
took it
100% so here's where we're at right now
the American software industry is racing
to release and refine AI language models
which I'll call chat bots in this video
it hasn't been obvious to everyone what
they should be used for but it has been
OB obvious to a lot of students the
freely available chat Bots can respond
to assignments across a bunch of middle
and high school subjects and the most
advanced models which you generally have
to pay for can analyze data read image
files and write at the college level
this summer I did the little research
project where I asked my freshman year
professors to grade essays written by
chat gbt and they got all as's and B's
and so this was just like very striking
to me I wanted to find out what this
means for education so I talk to
students from 8th grade to grad school I
talk to teachers and professors and
experts in learning and bear with us
because they're right in the middle of
this and it's complicated and they don't
really agree about how to proceed so
we'll also take a look at some of the
research on how learning works to see
how students can be strategic in the age
of
[Music]
AI we don't want to send that message to
our our young people you know to ignore
the things that scare us we have to
learn about it learn from it learn how
to use it but it's a lot of extra labor
and it's coming on the heels of like 3
years of pandemic based sort of
reworking of our teaching and so we're
all tired the the days of like giving
assignments to students and having them
work on it at home or over I would love
if they were using this as a great uh
thinking tool but that's that's really
not what's happening and so I think
educators are asking ourselves well how
do we know that students have
learned right now educ ERS face a choice
between two pretty murky paths they
could allow students to use this
technology or they could try to prevent
students from using it let's tackle that
one
first Banning AI looks like some
combination of blocking the websites on
school networks and computers using AI
detection software to try to catch
generated text and shifting more work
into class hours and onto paper but the
students and teachers that I spoke to
they don't love these options like I
don't want my students to feel like they
are under this kind of policing I go
from teacher to um sort of Hall Monitor
and that that's not that's not a
desirable teaching relationship but at
the same time I do want to know that
they're doing the work a lot of our kids
are really really good at getting around
the school firewalls but even if they
couldn't access it on their laptops I
mean they have it on their phones I'm
not letting them take anything home I
want everything to be written in class
the last two mid terms I had were in
class papers and it felt like I was in
high school and I hated it I really
don't know how you prevent students from
using AI because the detection softwares
are really imperfect there will will be
false positives and those false
positives are going to be awkward
situations with the teacher and a
student I have a problem accusing a kid
of using tgbt or using AI when I'm not
at 100% so I have found the detector
helpful it's not perfect we know it's
not perfect to avoid detection is
basically cycle it a couple times within
the software change whole sections of it
add sentences rol sentences and chances
are un fortunately professors are not
going to detect that one of my other
friends he's a great guy I'm not about
I'm going to say that he's like a
horrible person or something but like if
he can get away without getting caught
at all for like four terms I'm going to
be pretty skeptical of their AI
detection
abilities after chat GPT came out a
bunch of tools popped up saying that
they could detect AI writing but if you
look at open AI educator FAQ they say
detectors don't work so which is it well
they work sometimes that's the era we're
living in we have technologies that make
guesses we can say that the detectors
are generally more accurate on longer
samples of text and on text that hasn't
been edited at all some detectors may be
biased against non-native English
speakers so be careful there and you'll
want to check if the tool you're using
is transparent about how often it's
wrong I couldn't find error rates for
these detectors so who knows if they're
really testing the product there's an
alternative to detecting AI which is
certifying human writing by doing things
like tracking typing patterns and Pace
in time spent GPT Z's writing report
even offers a reenactment of the
document being
[Music]
written maybe more and more writing will
be done under this kind of surveillance
but it doesn't apply to other kinds of
assignments and at some point we have to
ask if it makes sense to prohibit chat
Bots for school when tech companies are
inserting them everywhere else rarly
notion Snapchat Google Docs they have
that help me write button that's built
right into the document raises the
question of do I have to site the work
of the AI now lest I face academic
consequences and students aren't the
only ones finding them useful I
immediately got really excited about
using it cuz I knew it would save hours
of my life syllabus day one of the first
things I said was I create a lot of
resources using chat GPT because it's a
good support for me creating readings
for students questions that your
students can answer for giving feedback
on essays it feels a little disingenuous
being like you can't use AI at all but
that I am using AI to generate the stuff
for this
class so let's take a look at the other
path which is allowing students to use
but not misuse AI chat Bots I I think AI
is a wonderful supplement to students
education Journeys as long it's used
responsibly if we don't embrace it while
we're in school which is where we learn
how to do things you're going to end up
with with a future generation that's
struggling um to adapt to its
surroundings we should be figuring out
how you know our students can benefit
from instead of just trying to outright
ban it um because that feels ridiculous
that feels absolutely
ridiculous the international Balor
program says AI shouldn't be banned
because it will become part of our
everyday lives like spell Checkers
translation software and
calculators calculators is not so scary
it frees up time on the tedious stuff so
that students can move on to more
complex problems but there are a couple
of ways that I'd say this is different
from that for one calculators don't make
things up and it gave me some quotes I
was like this is perfect but when I
tried to search it a few of these
sources into Google and all of them were
fake this quote isn't in the book like
they didn't exist at all I was able to
generate text about um the near
extinction of the the yagan people which
isn't true at all what's the difference
between a consequent boundary and
subsequent boundary and I don't remember
exactly what chat chbt said but they got
it wrong the less you know about
something the more likely you are to be
convinced by chat tbt's answer that was
when I really realized I was like this
is you have to be very careful so itical
literacy is important but we have that
problem with humans as
well chatbots work by predicting a
plausible sequence of words that makes
them more flawed than calculators and
spell Checkers but it also makes them
much more broad let me list some of the
things a student can ask a chatbot for
and while I do that think about which of
these you would consider a misuse
answers to a homework question
background information on a topic
definitions or explanations of a concept
sources to find more information
summaries of readings and lectures study
guides for an exam ideas for how to
respond to an assignment instructions
for solving a problem an outline for a
paper or presentation examples analogies
and counterarguments a draft of a paper
or a discussion post a script for a
presentation feedback on their work a
revision of a text to improve it a
revision of a text to change its word
count and more some of these definitely
seem helpful for learning but others
it's not so clear is it okay to ask a
chatbot for information I'll typically
ask Chachi PT just to summarize that
topic into easy to read bullet points I
don't see that as very different from
getting on Wikipedia most of the
students talked about using CBT in
particular almost as a kind of Wikipedia
and I really quickly was like ooh I
don't think that's the best way to use
these tools is it okay to get ideas from
a chatbot so I think in terms of
outlining and brainstorming I think
that's actually fairly low risk when it
comes to generating ideas it's not
really giving you an inspiration it's
giving you an answer one of my friends
and I were brainstorming different
topics and one was like no no quit quit
thinking I already look for it on chat
and I have this incredible idea and we
can Del it to this but we did write all
the text on our own it's not like we
Copan based because that is cheating
what about using AI to write a paper
after you've done the re search and
Analysis if it's all your ideas and
chadut is the editor the product is
still yours it's just been aided one of
the things that we do when we're writing
is we're figuring out what we think and
then chat gbt reorganizes things adds
some facts that I didn't know and then
my take is like yeah that's pretty much
what I said right and it's not
really I think the reason they disagree
on how to handle this tool is that it
isn't really a tool it wasn't built to
do some specific task now there will
will be AI tools that are constrained to
act more like tutors but open AI says
they're trying to build general
intelligence General meaning something
more like a student than a calculator
the difference is that calculators don't
do like don't make the equation for you
calculators don't like come up with a
creative solution meanwhile chbt gives
you all of the steps it's it's a I'd say
a lot easier at least for me to just
like read something and then write it
down then to like actually think about
something they're not going to get that
opportunity to sit there and really um
go from A to B to C um when chat GB can
go from a to c really quickly for them
you know maybe it's just easier to just
take the Chad GPT generation like the
generated response and then just tweak
it to sound more like me than to create
my own original piece of work if my work
is going to be like not as
[Music]
good
sometimes with the grades and the GPA
and everything it can feel like the
point of school assignments is to
evaluate students when really the point
is the learning that happens along the
way the grades are there to monitor the
learning and as my friend Denzel points
out you can't grade someone on something
that's not theirs so let's take a look
at how learning works and this is where
the challenge to education really lies
because technology is usually supposed
to make things easy but the research
shows that real learning requires things
to be a little bit hard let me give you
an example I use GPS almost constantly
to get around the city it tells me which
train or bus I need which subway exit to
take basically how to walk a bunch of
Studies have looked at how this affects
our spatial abilities because hey maybe
watching this app produce instructions
for my route is teaching me how to get
around you know it's giving me all of
these examples to learn from but no the
experiments consistently show that turn
BYT navigation leav leaves us with poor
spatial knowledge of the area and that's
because the tech lets us disengage from
our environment if I really wanted to
build a cognitive map of the space that
requires active engagement in the
navigation process and that means making
decisions which is hard and I may decide
that it's fine to offload my spatial
learning to this app and just expect
that it will always be there for me but
what about learning in other domains
like in
school there's a really interesting
study from a few years back where they
divided college students into two
classrooms that covered the exact same
physics lesson but in different ways so
one class presented the material in a
passive lecture and it was done in a way
that um it would mimic a lecture from a
super lecture you know like very smooth
very very fluent the other class used an
active learning method where the
students were put into small groups and
then given unfamiliar problems to work
on they weren't given much Direction so
it was a bit frustrating and then the
instructor would interrupt them and then
uh um explain basically give them the
feedback of how an expert thinks about
these things at the end of the class
they asked the students if they felt
like they learned a great deal from the
session and the students who received
the passive lecture said that they
learned more than those who did the
active learning class they were also
more likely to say that all of their
physics classes should be taught that
way they preferred just watching the
lecture but they were wrong tests on the
material showed that the students in the
active parti ipation class actually
learned more of the information it turns
out that we're not great at judging how
well we're learning whenever we try and
judge if a learning experience is
productive or not the strongest
metacognitive cue that we use um is
perception of fluency fluency is when
information is going down easy it's well
presented it's organized it's convenient
fluency is the reason why students tend
to reread their notes and textbooks when
they're studying when really they should
be giving themselves quizzes or trying
to explain the material in their own
words education researchers have this
term desirable difficulties which
describes this kind of effortful
participation that really works but also
kind of hurts and the risk with AI is
that we might not preserve that effort
especially because we already tend to
misinterpret a little bit of struggling
as a signal that we're not learning I
want them to know that struggling is
okay it's not about getting the right
answer it's not about having the correct
opinion you do not become a better
writer by just editing other people's
work you do it through the struggle the
text is kind of like the snake skin of
the growth you can replicate the snake
skin but there's a reason you toast me
in this room and the reason is the path
the reason isn't the
product so with all that said we can
look back at those prompts and ask is
this making the work easy for me or is
it motivating me to try the hard things
so you could use a chatbot to avoid
reading a challenging text or you could
use it to work through that text and
help you get more out of it tried to
read like the pros Eda it was just
impossible to read for me it was very
very hard I think that Chad might be
able to you know parse through some of
the harder language simplify things you
could use it to answer questions for you
or it could inspire you to ask questions
you wouldn't have asked before if you
have a question in class and you're not
sure what to do with it now your first
step instead of going to a teaching
assist or a friend might be to ask chat
gbt you could use it to write or rewrite
your words to sound perfect or you could
ask it to critique your writing and then
you decide how you want to make changes
you know where are there problems in the
logic where are there uh you know
sentences that aren't clear and so on
there's a there's a point in which the
student has to make that realization and
say okay this is where I need to work on
this and this is like this is where I
need to use chat PT and this is where I
need to not use chpt but I feel like
it's just like asking for trouble
because high schoolers
man our schools and teachers prompt us
to build our own mental map of the world
where we can connect ideas and
perspectives and knowledge across space
and time and you want to have that map
to help you navigate your future and
find your place in the human story but
from now on there will always be
companies offering you turn BYT
directions in dead and you might think
hey I'm a kid that's a lot of
self-regulation to ask from someone
whose brain is still cooking I mean
we're still trying to figure out how to
manage these things and adults don't
even know what AI is going to look like
in 10 years let alone what jobs will
exist isn't that kind of a lot to put on
us and my response to that is
yeah it
[Music]
is